Feeling hungry?
Maybe you could go for a snack right about
now, or a nice, refreshing can of your favorite
soda.
Perhaps, if you’ve got some change burning
a hole in your pocket, a nearby vending machine
would be a good choice.
And trust us, there’s no vending machine
like this one - SCP-261 will give you a treat
that’s out of this world.
Or rather, out of this dimension.
That’s how this Safe-class anomaly earned
its incredibly accurate name - the Interdimensional
Vending Machine.
It was first discovered in a dark alley in
Yokohama, Japan.
Japan is a place where you can find a number
of strange and surprising things in vending
machines, but nothing quite like this.
The Foundation was first alerted to its presence
after one of their webtrawlers noticed some
interesting chatter on Japanese online message
boards about a “magic vending machine.”
To these Japanese forum-users it sounded like
a fanciful urban legend, a vending machine
where you could get something truly fantastical
if you have the Yen to spare.
But upon thorough investigation, field agents
of the SCP Foundation discovered that the
machine was no legend and brought it into
containment.
It’s the kind of thing you wouldn’t look
twice at: An utterly generic black vending
machine with no viewing window, and a hand-written
sign in Japanese that reads “Out of Order.”
But what the vending machine looks like isn’t
nearly as interesting as what it’s capable
of.
When you insert your money into the machine
- and it’s important to note that it only
accepts Japanese Yen - the machine will dispense
some kind of snack-food or drink item.
However, over time, the more the machine is
used in a single day, the more bizarre the
items it spits out will become.
Foundation researchers have attempted to figure
out how the machine works, but their task
has been incredibly difficult so far.
It doesn’t appear to contain any snacks,
and it doesn’t seem to be made of any anomalous
parts.
Moreover, the machine simply won’t work
when the front panel is opened, or when any
surveillance equipment is placed inside.
In other words, it’s pretty much impossible
to look this gift horse in the mouth.
Strangely, the machine is also capable of
working without power, though when unpowered
the vended products are likely to become stranger
much faster.
But let’s be honest here: You’re not here
for Vending Machine Mechanics 101, you want
to hear about all the weird stuff that SCP-261
dispenses, and frankly, we’re with you on
that one.
Lucky for all of us, this is one of the anomalies
that the Foundation has truly extensive test
records on, providing us with a highlight
reel of some of the strangest, wildest, and
downright most interesting snacks and drinks
straight out of another dimension.
Bon appetit!
Let’s start off nice and easy with some
of the snacks and drinks that are not only
edible, but also sound like they’d actually
be pretty tasty.
Like “Pepsi: Dragon Twist”, a bottle of
Pepsi soda with English packaging that tastes
like dragon fruit.
PepsiCo does not produce such a product, but
honestly, we wish they did.
Same for Darkside Cola, a clear liquid that
becomes jet black shortly after being opened,
which apparently tastes like your average
can of Coke, with a touch of spice thrown
in.
But hey, not everybody likes cola - maybe
you’re a maverick, a rebel, only a soft
drink with a formal title can quench your
thirst, and as such, you prefer Dr. Pepper.
In which case, maybe the vending machine will
furnish you with an interdimensional Japanese
product known as “Dr. Pepper’s Amusing
Straw.”
This spatial anomaly wrapped inside a whimsical
Dr. Pepper branded straw seems to contain
far more liquid than should be able to fit
in the straw, about one bottle’s worth of
soda’s to be precise.
A nice and convenient solution for whenever
you need to get the fix that only an accredited
doctor of pop-ology can provide!
And if you fancy something from the more intoxicating
end of the beverage spectrum, for 600 Yen
you can get yourself a rare bottle of “BILLY
BEER”.
It’s just the thing for those who weren’t
alive during the Carter administration but
still want to try brew that was endorsed by
the younger brother of President Jimmy Carter.
This anomalous bottle of suds which was bottled
in the 1970s according to its label, came
with a note reading, “I had this beer brewed
just for me.
I think it's the best I've ever tasted.
And I've tasted a lot.
I think you'll like it too.
Billy Carter.”
Drinking the beer got a D-Class intoxicated
for 72 hours.
But what if you’ve just wet your whistle
and worked up a hunger in the process?
Thankfully, SCP-261 has some delicious interdimensional
food to satisfy your cravings.
So for starters, how about a tube of “The
Little Bakery: 7 Grain”?
This small aluminum tube lets you squeeze
out a blob of dough, which instantaneously
rises and cooks itself into a tasty little
loaf of bread.
Testing has indicated that the bread is a
little chewy, but still tastes completely
fine.
Not bad for a tubed baked good.
How about some seafood to go with that bread?
Then maybe for your entree you can crack open
a delicious pack of Lemon Clams?
And we do mean “crack” very literally
here.
If you crack this bag of anomalous clams like
a glowstick, they boil themselves, and once
you open them, you’re ready to enjoy a serving
of tasty clams that have a slight lemon flavoring
to them.
Delicious!
But if you’re not that hungry and just feeling
more like a snack than a full fancy dinner,
the machine once put out the Lay’s Blooming
Onion.
While it appears to be a normal onion, each
layer of the onion is a different flavor of
chip, leading all the way into the middle.
Truly, a gourmet snack with more layers than…
well… actually exactly as many layers as
an onion.
And what about for those who are anomalously
trapped in the year 2012 and are looking for
a snack that is both tasty AND meme worthy?
Well you’ll be be lucky to receive a 700
Yen “Bacon Shirt”.
It’s exactly what it says on the can - an
edible shirt that both smells and tastes like
bacon, and has no real side effects other
than making you smell a little like bacon
while you’re wearing it.
Though this could be a dangerous anomalous
effect is you decide to walk through your
local dog park while you’re wearing it.
We’ve been told it pairs well with the “Meathat:
Teriyaki Fedora”, a size-64, trilby-style
fedora made entirely out of Teriyaki-flavored
beef jerky.
The object came flattened in a cardboard box
bearing the tagline, "You can have your hat,
and eat it too!", which is a pun that probably
makes a lot more sense in their dimension.
Still a bit hungry?
Well lucky for you, this magical vending machine
has got you covered on dessert too.
For 700 Yen, the Foundation was given an entire
edible chess set, with each of the ornate
pieces carved from what seemed like hard PEZ-style
candy.
It’s less checkmate and more check… ate.
Another pun that I promise is funnier in another
dimension.
And for 300 Yen extra, you might walk away
with a candy robot playset.
These are more hard-candy components that
can be put together to create functional,
anomalous mini-robots that move on their own,
walking aimlessly and bumping into the walls.
But what about the full meal craving consumer
on the go?
Who wants both a dinner and dessert combined
into one disgusting package?
Don’t worry, the Interdimensional Vending
Machine has you covered.
Just 400 Yen can net you some delicious Turduchocken.
These are balls of fried turkey, filled with
chocolate, a smaller ball of duck, more chocolate,
and in the very center, a small ball of…
fried chicken.
Even the labeling on the product describes
it as having 450% of an adult human’s daily
recommended fat intake.
We’ll leave it to you to decide if this
is a decadent treat worthy of the gods, or
utterly disgusting.
Maybe you’re feeling a little cheeky though?
Or you need the perfect comedic dessert for
your bachelorette party?
The vending machine has a candy direct from
an alternate Korea: A tasty - if slightly
too sweet - chocolate candy shaped like a
certain male organ, filled with, we kid you
not, liquid white chocolate.
Perfect for anyone who has both the sweet
tooth and the sense of humor of a twelve year
old!
Okay, these were definitely all weird treats,
but let’s get really, really strange now
- from the disgusting, to the confusing, to
the inedible, to the straight-up deadly.
If you’re a bit of a sadist, perhaps you’re
the kind of person who enjoys watching their
snacks dying in front of them before they
eat them.
For that, the vending machine provides an
aluminum box with a viewing window and a red
button on top.
Inside are a collection of small, furry creatures,
each with a single, big eye.
When the button is pressed, the creatures
inside are abruptly superheated, cooking them
all to death.
At that point, the box opens, and the creatures
are ready to eat.
We’ve been told they were crunchy, spicy,
and tasted a little like beef.
Maybe you’re part of the slow food movement.
For that, we recommend the delicious Pile
O’ Slugs, which is exactly what it sounds
like.
This is a produce box, like the kind used
for packing strawberries, except it’s full
of live slugs.
There are both advantages and disadvantages
to actually eating these slugs - the advantage
is that they contain large amounts of vitamin
C, E, and most of the B complex, which are
all crucial to a healthy and balanced diet.
The disadvantage is that they contain large
amounts of arsenic, which will kill you.
Though of course, if you still have a candy-flavored
death wish, but you prefer your entomological
treats a little more leggy, then may we interest
you in a fine caramelized spider for a modest
500 Yen?
It’s full of deadly quantities of an unknown,
anomalous venom that’s pretty much impossible
to cure, but it’s worth it for the sweet,
sticky goodness that comes before death sets
in.
Another strange item dispensed by the vending
machine was a tall, metal aluminum canister
with a ring pull, that - upon opening - had
a violent chemical reaction with the air and
triggered a large explosion.
Apparently, this particular beverage was never
intended for oxygenated environments.
The blast killed two researchers, and resulted
in the temporary suspension of testing.
Though in a slight silver lining for this
fiasco, the testing area did smell of citrus
for a few days, which the janitors must have
enjoyed as they cleaned up all the body parts.
Another dangerous snack provided by the vending
machine was a long tube of chips called “Prangles”,
not to be confused with any other long, tube-based
chips you may be thinking of.
When the tube was opened, or “popped”
as they say, the D-Class that the chips were
presented to began compulsively eating them.
When researchers ordered the D-Class to stop,
it seemed almost as though they couldn’t.
Regardless of the orders given to them, the
D-Class just kept eating.
Even when guards terminated the D-Class there
and then, the corpse continued to eat chips
out of the tube, until it was physically pried
out of their hands.
But if all those salty Prangles have really
worked up a thirst in you, perhaps you can
wash them down with a delicious can of Cherry
Bomb, an intense, cherry-flavored drink dispensed
by SCP-261 for 450 Yen?
When a D-Class sampled this delicious soda,
they commented on it tasting strongly of cherry.
A few moments later, their head exploded with
the force of a stick of dynamite, coating
everyone and everything around it in gooey
head viscera.
The resulting cleanup took an arduous six
hours, but wow, was that cherry tasty.
And finally, why not complete this anomalous
vending machine feast with a 1000 Yen papier-mâché
piñata, resembling a dead horse, that comes
ready to use with a baseball bat.
Everyone who saw the pinata felt compelled
to beat it mercilessly with the bat, until
candy began to fall out.
Many in attendance claimed that it was the
1,000th gift unleashed by SCP-261, and thus,
warranted celebration.
Once the dead horse was thoroughly beaten,
all cognitohazardous properties ceased.
There’s a joke somewhere in there, but for
the life of us, we’re not sure we can find
it…
Oh well… maybe it’s in another dimension.
Now go check out “SCP-978 - Desire Camera”
and “SCP-5031 - Yet Another Murder Monster”
for more SCPs that are surprisingly useful!